[Music]
hey you guys welcome back to tomes of
terror where we talk about horror books
so as i've probably mentioned on this
series before
i don't usually put a great deal of
conscious thought into what books i'm
going to be reading for the tombs of
terror series unless you know for
example one of you guys or you know some
like a reviewer i trust or something
like that makes a specific
recommendation most of the time what i
will do is i'll just kind of browse
through whatever is available to read
for free on kindle unlimited that has
like a decently high rating and
has a cover or a title that looks kind
of like interesting to me
and this was the manner that i stumbled
across the book that i'm talking about
today which is tj payne's 2019 novel
intercept
now this book actually kept turning up
at the top of my kindle recommendations
and i actually checked it out like into
my library a long time ago because i
actually meant to get to it a couple
months ago but then other books
intervened like some people sent me some
books that i reviewed and some other
things occurred so i didn't really get a
chance to read it until recently now i
will say that even though i've been
excited about reading it the cover
looked kind of interesting but to be
honest i thought that it was going to be
like just judging by the cover i thought
it was going to be like a ghost story
maybe about evps i don't know why like
the cover kind of gave me that
impression which would have been fine
or i thought it was going to be like a
science fiction story like maybe about
aliens which i would have been like kind
of meh about
however i am happy to report that it is
neither of those things
while intercepts does have kind of like
a veneer of science fiction
this is a horror story through and
through and i mean it is pretty damn
gory also
now i read through this one at like a
lightning speed uh really eager to see
what the hell was gonna happen next it's
very very briskly paced it's very
action-packed and it kind of just like
sucks you right in from the very
beginning with like this whole mystery
of like what exactly is like going on
here and then like as it goes on it just
keeps steadily like ramping up the
stakes and ramping up the violence um
until you get to the ending which is
kind of like pretty balls to the wall
it's also i have to say one of very few
horror novels that i've read
where
there really aren't any
all good guys or all bad guys and you
know i i know that's not that rare but
i'm just saying that
in the sense that everybody in this um
well most people in this like have done
kind of terrible things but
i think like the magic of the book is
that the reader can sympathize with
everyone's perspective because everyone
is just very
nuanced and very human and it's like
they do terrible things but you can kind
of like understand how they got into
that position and things like that so
to me like the moral ambiguity i guess
of the story was a real highlight um
because it's sort of like mirrored
reality to quite an uncomfortable extent
but i really really did like
kind of where it was coming from with
that so at the start of the novel you
get this kind of brief prologue in which
someone is talking about they seem to be
like in some kind of limbo state like
unaware of who they are or where they
are they can't seem to see or hear
anything they can't like feel their body
or like tell if they're moving or even
tell if they're inside a body and their
consciousness just kind of seems to be
floating out there in the ether
so then we delve into the story proper
now most of the book is told from the
point of view of like a middle-aged guy
named joe gerhard and he seems like a
very amiable regular joe type of guy
now he manages a very secret secret
secret government facility that is kind
of hidden in the hills of i think it's
west virginia somewhere
and a lot of the beginning of the story
is like establishing just how covert
this place is and the security measures
that have kind of been undertaken to
ensure that nobody in the outside world
like figures out exactly what's going on
there the great thing about this story
and what makes it feel a lot more kind
of grounded in reality i guess
is that in spite of the super-duper
classified nature of the work that goes
on in this place which is only ever
referred to as the company or the
facility
um it's very clear that the project
whatever it is like you find out
still suffers from just cost cutting
measures and bureaucratic [ __ ] in
other words this is kind of like no
ultra high tech concern like you would
maybe see like in a big budget hollywood
science fiction movie where everything
is just kind of like top of the line
this is just an average workplace uh
with just average ass people like
working joe people like working there
like getting donuts from the break room
and [ __ ] like that um and there's also
like your regular stuff like you would
have at any workplace there's just kind
of like idiotic rules that don't that
are completely ineffective and don't do
anything um the higher-ups don't have
any idea what's going on at the ground
level which is one of the reasons they
come up with all these stupid rules that
don't do anything and which it takes
kind of like a metaphorical or actually
maybe in this case maybe a literal like
act of congress just to get that one
damn broken urinal fix like in the men's
room it's like that kind of thing it's
kind of like simultaneously comforting
and also kind of horrifying to think
that even these top secret government
projects with ostensibly unlimited
funding
uh kind of suffer from the same
workplace inefficiency and
disorganization and just stupidity as
any other company in the world so you
know now joe our main character is very
very proud of the job he does at the
facility like one of the things that
he's really proud about is that he's
kind of like a southern guy west
virginia guy he didn't like go to any
fancy college or anything like that but
he like worked his way up and made
himself like invaluable by pretty much
knowing everything about how this whole
facility functions and he got to a point
where they couldn't really manage the
place without him and he's actually like
really proud of being able to do that
even though like i said he's not from
some elite school or anything like that
and he's also really kind of like earned
the respect and the friendship of
everybody who works there he's like i
said very down to earth very folksy and
he thinks that he gets a lot better
results by being friends with him his
employees like being warm with them but
being firm you know kind of like giving
him some leeway and like shooting the
[ __ ] and everything like that instead of
like being like a hard ass or like
really authoritarian
so what exactly does this facility do
you might ask now i will warn you like i
said i'm not going to spoil the ending
or anything like that but just as with a
lot of these videos i tend to go like a
little bit in depth about what's going
on with the plot and i know that some
people would rather just come to
stories like without knowing anything
about them and i'm like that too which
is why i don't read or reviews or watch
reviews of movies or books or anything
like that until after i've seen them
because i'm interested in other people's
perspective on it so if you want to come
into this like not knowing anything else
about it obviously then stop now and
turn back and like go read it it's free
on kindle unlimited and then come back
and talk about it like i said i'm not
going to spoil the ending but you might
not want to know some of the stuff that
i'm going to talk about from this point
forward so you have been warned
so what does this facility do
now if you've ever read anything about
the real life stargate project which i
think most people know what that is but
if you don't uh it was this project in
which the army and the defense
intelligence agency were experimenting
with remote viewing so it's like
somebody that was psychic and they could
kind of maybe cast their consciousness
you know in theory uh to
other parts like you know behind the
iron curtain or whatever the hell um and
could tell you like information like
kind of give you into you know it was
for intelligence gathering applications
they're essentially using psychic powers
for that kind of thing so the facility
in intercepts is doing basically the
same thing and there's also kind of like
a little bit of a hint of minority
report in the whole uh scheme as well
okay so the facility houses a dozen men
and women they're called antennas
and they've basically been imprisoned in
these cells and given a particular type
of what i could determine was like an
experimental nerve gas and it seems to
like suppress all of their sensory
apparatus so like they can't see
anything in the room they can't hear
anything in the room they're like you
know what i mean it's i don't want to
say they're in a vegetative state but
because they can still move around and
like make noise and stuff but they can't
perceive anything in their immediate
environment let's put it that way now
keeping the antennas in this limbo state
they have discovered uh in which they
can basically do nothing but roll around
on the floor of their cell like mumble
and occasionally scream like i said they
have to have like people come in and
like change their diapers and feed them
and stuff like that because they can't
uh they don't know anything that's going
on around them
so keeping them in this state they found
out like accidentally at some point in
the past
um actually heightens their senses
immeasurably it's almost kind of like
putting them into sensory deprivation
and then
like while they're in the sensory
deprivation like all the time like when
they get brought out of it like all of
their senses kind of like are are
heightened you know what i mean so
whenever the staff at the facility or
the higher-ups rather like when they get
asked to
like we need some information about this
terrorist attack or this head of a drug
cartel or this arms dealer or whatever
the hell
then the staff will pick one of the
antennas and they will do something
called tuning them
which basically entails turning off the
nerve gas that they keep them on all the
time and it kind of causes all of their
senses to like rush back in in this
state they actually like are getting
like all these flows of information and
they found that like all this
information is actually really good like
actionable intelligence because they're
getting stuff like from the ether
now the sad thing about this though i
mean like i said it is very effective
they can give all this you know
information that is proven to be correct
about whatever target that they're
that they've chose to like tune into it
also causes the antennas themselves
horrible excruciating pain and really
like unbearable mental anguish like i
said he he describes it like joe
describes it at one point it's like hey
you know like when you know you fall
asleep on your arm and like your arms
asleep and then you wake it up and it's
like and it's really really painful like
as the sensation comes back into it he's
like it's like that but like a million
times worse like because they can't feel
their bodies and they can't see but then
everything comes like rushing back to
them at once when they take them off the
nerve gas and it's like really
horrifying for them now over time the
staff of the facility have kind of had
to train themselves to see the antennas
as pieces of equipment rather than human
beings
nobody in the facility uh knows where
the antennas came from or who they were
in their former lives and they've kind
of learned not to ask it's very much
like a not my problem above my pay grade
type of thing
now although it is protocol to you know
across all of the sites because it's
implied that there's more than one but
this is like the most effective or most
you know the one that has the most
intelligence it's protocol to refer to
them by their numbers to further
dehumanize them but at this particular
facility where joe works they've
actually given the antennas names
because they think it makes it easier to
like refer to them like hey go clean up
whoever instead of 201 or 301 or
whatever and rather hilariously as well
as kind of ghoulishly i will say the
head doctor at the company is actually a
very likable character named dr hannah
chow
and she has named them all after
characters in her favorite movie which
is aliens so all of the antennas are
named like bishop and vasquez and
pharaoh and gorman and crow and so forth
so they're all kind of named that which
i thought was very funny like because
they didn't actually explain that until
later on but i'm like these are all
names from aliens so yeah i thought that
was really funny now back to joe
so as likeable a character as joe is and
he is very likable he was also in the
past kind of a neglectful husband to his
wife kate and you know a neglectful
father to his teenage daughter riley so
several years ago kate divorced him and
riley went to live with her although she
still visits her dad on the weekends now
he feels bad that he missed like a large
portion of his daughter's childhood
because of his work
but he kind of tries to justify it
somewhat by telling himself well i'm
doing necessary work for national
security and by protecting the country
i'm indirectly protecting my own family
as well somebody's got to do it might as
well be me and like i said he is very
proud of his work but like i said it's
kind of a double-edged sword not too
long into the story though joe gets the
very shocking news that his ex-wife kate
has committed suicide which seems like
something that she wouldn't do so it's
like very confusing for him now riley
who at this point is 16 or 17 years old
uh she comes to live with him and he
hopes that he'll be able to kind of like
bridge the distance that's developed
between them over the years since they
got divorced and you find out later on
that the divorce was actually kind of
his fault because like as some [ __ ] up
[ __ ] that he did
however shortly after riley moves in
she starts seeing things uh specifically
she starts seeing this terrifying
looking woman with
deathly pale skin and greasy black hair
and she's wearing what appears to be a
hospital gown
now
alarmingly no one else seems to be able
to see her and at first
you know when she tells her dad about it
and tells hannah about it and stuff like
that they kind of think well you know
the kid's mom just
died very suddenly in a very horrible
traumatic way so obviously this is like
some grief processing because this woman
that she's seeing
kind of looks she knows that it's not
her mom but it kind of looks enough like
her mom that people are like thinking
that as the story goes on though like
everybody just thinks oh you know she'll
work through it because she's just
having problems because of grief or
whatever but as the story goes on and
strange things start happening at joe's
workplace as well that seem to be
connected with riley's sightings of this
woman whoever she is uh it starts to
become clear that something profound and
probably very very dangerous uh might be
happening within the minds of the
antennas that are being kept at this
facility so as i mentioned this was
actually a great read i mean it just
kind of like moved right along like
breakneck speed and it gets more and
more messed up like as it goes along now
the characters most of which worked at
the facility doing what are obviously
horrible things to helpless human beings
uh were still sympathetic because
they just came across as just kind of
like regular working people with their
own problems uh that just had a job to
do and tried not to think too hard about
like the bigger implications or
consequences of the work that they were
doing so you could kind of sympathize
with them to the extent that it's like
you could put yourself in
in their shoes um even though you
obviously don't you know want to think
that it's like well i would never like
do a job like that but it's just kind of
like but they were still like good
people you know what i'm saying um and
on the other hand you also felt really
bad for the antennas obviously because
they were
as i said helpless human beings you
don't really know where they came from
they could have just been snatched up
off the street for all you know or they
could have been like political prisoners
who knows where they came from and then
they're doing these horrible things like
they shave their heads and like they're
just laying there pooping themselves and
[ __ ] like that and they're just like
inflicting horrible pain on them and so
they're doing that
so you can kind of like
understand their anguish and their
motivations as well so the story was
actually really kind of nuanced in that
way it didn't really let any of the
characters off the hook for the stuff
that they did but
it also made you as the reader kind of
see how they got into the position of
doing those things and you could see how
that could happen you know what i mean
um so
overall like coming at it from that
angle it was kind of like a real
compelling take on how easy it is for
evil outcomes to maybe like emerge from
confused bureaucracies even if no one
within those bureaucracies is a
particularly bad person so it's kind of
that sort of thing you know what i mean
so if you're at all into kind of like
government conspiracy type stuff or
stuff that could maybe like marginally
be termed science fiction about you know
secret agencies doing human
experimentation like especially like in
regards to psychic abilities you know
stuff like my mention minority report or
maybe something like fire starter or
scanners or altered states or the fury
or something like that where there's
like some kind of faceless corporation
that's trying to weaponize psychic
powers essentially uh then you'll
probably really dig this because this is
right along those lines uh but keep in
mind that the sci-fi element while it is
a significant part of the story is kind
of more in service to the horror like i
said this is a horror story it's not
really a science fiction story you know
what i mean it has science fiction
elements but it's mostly a horror story
and uh believe me when i say that this
thing does get skin peelingly gory and i
actually do mean that quite literally so
if you're squeamish uh might want to
give it a pass there's like a lot of
people being torn apart and like stuff
like that so if you don't like that kind
of thing then maybe don't because
there's a lot of that in here but you
know what i mean uh but everybody else
should definitely check it out uh i
thought it was outstanding and it really
kind of like kept me engaged from the
first page and also had like a really
good like kind of gut punch of an ending
i think i don't know like i don't want
to say i necessarily saw the ending
coming but i was just kind of like it
almost had like this real like i don't
want to say depressing but like a real
like [ __ ] like inevitability to it
you're just like yeah of course you know
what i mean it was just that kind of
ending but yeah i mean if you have
kindle unlimited then i would definitely
recommend it it was real good i had a
good time with it and that will do it
for this tomes of terror and i will see
you guys again on the next one
bye